[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: In order to
prevent global warming
from reaching 1.5 degrees,
it's estimated that the next 10
years are crucial for us to
collaborate across sectors
to remove and prevent carbon
pollution, which is also
known as greenhouse gases.
An incredibly interdisciplinary
open data project
called Climate
TRACE is presently
led by 10 entities, and former
Vice President, Al Gore,
and is collaborating with
over 50 organizations
to come together and help
detect where carbon pollution is
presently coming from by
country, and even by industry,
using satellite images
and machine learning.
Soon, it will
transparently publish
where pollution arises from
a particular factory, a coal
plant, an agricultural field,
an animal farm, et cetera.
The intention behind creating
this global inventory
of emissions is to help
policymakers, industry
operators, and even
consumers who may unknowingly
be investing in
high-polluting organizations,
and take actions quickly to
prevent a climate crisis.
Because the energy sector
is currently a top focus,
in this episode,
we walk through how
to generate a geospatial
classification model that
passes the image of
a coal power plant
from a satellite
called Sentinel-2,
and tells us whether
that plant is on or off.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Thanks to data, today, we can
understand our natural world
with far greater
richness than ever
before by orders of magnitude.
This now empowers us to
build amazing apps that
can help us solve complex social
and environmental challenges.
And so in this series,
let's build an app together.
Meet Gavin, who is Executive
Director at Watttime, which
is a nonprofit that helps
the public understand
how clean is the electricity
I'm using right now using
technology.
Historically, it's been
challenging to measure this.
GAVIN MCCORMICK: The
global state of the art
mostly is self-reporting
just asking emitters
how much they emit.
And in some cases, having
extremely expensive
on-site equipment at individual
power plants and factories.
A couple of governments around
the world, but very few,
have open power
plant monitoring.
And they monitor their
heaviest sources of emissions
and divide that data
free to the public.
For most sources of
emissions around the world,
there is no equivalent system.
And so it wasn't the
case that we could just
add up all of the open
data and process that
into a global emission system.
We actually needed to go out and
create the emissions databases
that we were aggregating to have
a sense of global emissions.
SPEAKER: Climate TRACE'S
web app and data set
uses publicly available
satellite data
from Earth Engine, as well
as privately owned data.
And all the compute
processing and classifying
of the 59 trillion bytes of
data from over 11,000 sensors
that come from
hundreds of satellites
is done on Google Cloud by using
products such as TensorFlow
and Vertex AI for training
and labeling data, BigQuery
and Earth Engine for data
analysis, and Kubernetes
Engine for container
management, just to name a few.
GAVIN MCCORMICK: Without
Google, this project really
would have never happened.
We submitted a grant
application for what we thought
was a little bit of a
pie in the sky moonshot.
We thought if this worked,
it would be amazing.
Google took a really
big bet on a project
back when it was just an idea.
They gave us a
generous $1.7 million
grant to make the
project possible.
And then they doubled-down.
They said, you know what?
We really want this
project to succeed.
And we're going to send seven
engineers full-time for six
months to help accelerate
this team of scientists
to make sure the
machine learning
and the data engineering
really are successful.
They then further doubled-down
to support the coalition
as this project matured,
growing from an initial idea
around power plants to
the new Climate TRACE
concept of monitoring
all GHG emissions.
SPEAKER: I am beyond impressed
and very proud by this project,
and send a warm-hearted shout
out to all the volunteers
and organizations who have
made this idea become reality.
For those of us equally
interested in working
with AI and satellite
imagery, let's go a bit deeper
on how we could
approach this problem.
Let's start with understanding
our inputs and outputs.
Our input data comes
from Sentinel-2,
which is a satellite owned
by the European Space Agency.
Multi-spectral images
of the entire planet
are taken every 10
days since 2015.
Every pixel in these
images approximately
covers a 10 meter
by 10 meter area.
When working with
satellite data,
each input image has dimensions
of width, height, and bands.
Bands are measurements from
specific satellite instruments
for different ranges of the
electromagnetic spectrum.
For example, Sentinel-2
contains 13 spectral bands.
If you are familiar with
image classification problems,
you can think of the
bands similar to images
as red, green,
blue, RGB channels.
However, when working
with satellite data,
we generally have more
than just three bands.
As for outputs, in this
example, the output
is a single number
between 0-off, and 1-on,
representing the probability
of that coal plant being on.
Next, let's move on to
building a data set.
Climate TRACE went
through the labor
of love of labeling lat-long
locations of coal plants
that correspond to Sentinel-2
images, and shared it as a CSV.
Each coal plants location is
on or off at different times.
Next, we used Earth Engine
to get the band values
for a patch of pixels given
their lat-long timestamp
and on or off label from
each row of the CSV file.
We basically view the
band values as the data,
and the label as the answer.
From this, we randomly
split this data
into training and
validation data sets
and saved them as TF
records in Cloud Storage.
For this case, we split
it into 70% training
and 30% validation data sets.
This means the model studies and
learns from the training data
sets, while the validation
data set is used like an exam
to make sure it's
learning to generalize
to data it hasn't seen before.
Next, we use Vertex AI, Google's
machine learning platform
to train and validate the model.
We use a convolutional
neural network,
which is an ML technique that
works well with image data.
It receives a patch of
pixels where the power
plant is at its center.
And as a friendly note,
each pixel in Sentinel-2s
is approximately 10 meters.
So we decided to use a padding
of 16 pixels around the plant.
That means that our 33 by 33
patch is around 330 meters
by 330 meters.
Because of this,
our training data
is a consistent patch
of 33 by 33 pixels.
And the model returns the
probability of the plant being
on.
Once we're happy with our model,
it is stored into Cloud Storage
as well.
And in order to use that
model to make predictions
of coal plants, we
deploy it on Cloud Run,
and make it a
predictions service.
And when done, we celebrate
with a dance party.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
So what's next?
If you would like to review
this process in greater
detail in the
description below, I
have included the link to
an interactive notebook
with all the code used to build
a sample, written by Nikita,
a super passionate peer of mine.
You can also find a blog post
and several helpful resources
too.
And community, I'll
leave you with a fun
fact from Gavin about the
project before we end.
And if you found
this content helpful,
you can subscribe or leave
a comment on other AI
for good use cases
you may have in mind.
Cheers.
GAVIN MCCORMICK: One fun
surprise about this project
is, I didn't know how
much the satellites that
orbit the Earth today are
mostly designed for maps.
So that we can all drive
where we need to go,
nearly every satellite
has been designed
to land at about
11:00 AM overhead.
Problem is, what
if you're trying
to see the emissions
of something that
doesn't happen at 11:00 AM?
We've had to call
increasingly obscure agencies
around the world of
various countries
that happen some time to
launch a satellite that's
good at seeing things
at night, and we've
gotten to just how many
satellites are designed to see
things right before noon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]